as you may have heard president Trump
recently admitted he admitted that he
lied to Canada's Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau during a recent discussion they
had about trade that's right
Trump said he made up deficit claims in
talk with Trudeau and in Canadians are
angry
many people unhappy about this no one
more so than our shows one and only
Canadian writer Levi MacDougall now he
has asked me because Canadians are
furious he's asked me to come out for a
moment to deliver a strongly worded
statement to President Trump on behalf
of all Canadians yeah I saw him in the
hallway and he looked I've never seen
him so riled up yeah it's a whole new
side of Levi pure anger it's something
he feels he needs to address so please
welcome our Canadian writer Levi
mcdougal
[Applause]
thanks Conan thanks President Trump you
told a lie to our Prime Minister the
Honourable Justin Trudeau and in doing
that you lie to all Canadians so on
behalf of all my countrymen please
listen closely to what I'm about to say
hey don't okay
Levi just calm down try to breathe just
breathe I know and and I'm sorry but I
can't hold back
president Trump stop it okay calm down
Levi look we we don't like how it feels
and and if you lie to us one more time
we also won't like how it feels then
Levi take it easy well take it easy as
soon as your president starts lying so
sounds like I'll never take it easy ever
all right I'm sorry he's out of control
can we get security in here please
security okay son gonna have come with
me
okay look I'm sorry but you mess with a
moose you get the antlers
[Applause]
Levi Google everybody I'm sorry for that
you